with lake mead at historic lows most of
us are thinking about how to save water
one local couple doing their part and
also cashing in for their efforts we're
going to meet them this morning it's all
thanks to southern nevada water
authority's turf rebate program which
translates into cash for grass mary jane
belliesa is live now in henderson with
more good morning mary jane
good morning sherry we're actually in
the front yard of wes's roberts home out
here in henderson and wes thank you so
much for joining us bright and early i
mean this is a really unique and
obviously creative way to kind of help
save money really bring awareness to the
community how to save and conserve water
as well as cash in on this program can
you tell us how much money you're saving
right now i think probably 50 to 60
dollars a month i think i said before
i've turned the watering system off
completely because all of our plants are
drought tolerant if something needs it
we'll hit it you know with a gallon or
two of water but what we went from
a lot
to basically just about nothing other
than what we use in the house oh
absolutely and you know this is such a
beautiful mural that you have here that
really matches the golf theme you have
going on right yeah yeah yeah it does so
uh
uh as i said before that's augusta in
atlanta georgia
uh and and it's just kind of my world
when i come out here and look at it
wishing i was there i know it's such a
beautiful space and i know too that
probably a lot of the neighborhood comes
in and
sits down and well we have people
stopping out front and i'm
first off i go what are you doing out in
front of my house then i understood
they're looking and pointing at the
mural
so uh yeah i mean it's such a great way
to let people know you can save water
but also do it beautifully creatively
and also everything here i can see is
desert friendly it is everything's
drought tolerant and i just wanted
something to soften the the desert
landscaping a bit so that's why we did
what we did that'll hurt yeah thank you
so much you know it's such a creative
and unique way that you can also save
money and do your part as well we're in
the beautiful backyard of west roberts
henderson home and just take a look at
everything here it's so gorgeous and wes
thank you so much for joining us bright
and early this morning you did mention
that southern nevada water authority
paid you three dollars a square foot
right right yeah it was they paid us 1
000 50
and that covered two-thirds of what we
did so it was very helpful to us yeah
and i know that with the turf as well as
the mural everything just seems like it
came together so well it's so beautiful
and that was the idea yeah i i want to
soften the desert landscaping a little
bit and we couldn't be happier and the
neighbors as well oh i'm sure they'll
probably come by all the time and take a
look at it yeah they do yeah i actually
take pictures of it oh wow can you tell
us a little bit about the mural that you
have here well it's wall sensations from
phoenix arizona and that's there's
thousands of holes in that and it'll
stand up to very high winds i think i
think it's warranted five or ten years
the sun's not going to damage it
and it just wouldn't be the same
backyard without that to me oh
absolutely and you made such a you know
beautiful way to mesh it all together
especially with the turf too how much
water are you saving
you know we save so much 50 to 60 a
month but we don't water this at all
we went from
watering all the time to zero
and everything here is desert friendly
too even
african sumac trees uh
we don't water them so we do bottom a
little bit we have our washer out here
yeah but not as much exactly right yeah
so yeah right yeah it turned out very
nice yeah at first let me say thank you
channel 8 for coming out to our house oh
of course and thank you guys for you
know bringing awareness of the community
such a really creative and beautiful way
to save water and also bring awareness
to such an important issue wes thank you
so much reporting live in henderson mary
jane bellassa live local now